Willkommen zum chaosradio 293. Und wir haben heute eine schwierige situation, denn unser Moderator, Markus Richter, ist tatsächlich in seinen natürlich wohl verdienten Urlaub abgeschwört und hat uns hier ganz alleine gelassen. Wir haben aber beschlossen, dass wir keine Sommerpause machen, denn wir haben wichtige Themen, da müssen wir drüber sprechen und müssen wir ohne Markus irgendwie hinkriegen. Aber ich habe zwei unfassbar gute Gäste, die auch eloquent sind, technische Ahnung haben und diese chaosradio trotzdem ohne Markus rocken werden. Wir haben zum einen zu meiner Linken kein Taukel, der extra für uns angereist ist aus Berlin, naja, war nicht so weit. Und dann haben wir Erdgeist, ein häufiger Gast im chaosradio. Hallo Erdgeist.
Hallo Konz.
Das bin ich. Wir haben heute eigentlich so ein bisschen klassische Folge vom chaosradio, würde ich sagen, weil wir ein bisschen über natürlich Technik reden wollen, auch ein bisschen erklär werden, aber wir haben auch einen Hack, den wir als konkreten Anlass haben. Also eigentlich ist es eine gute Mischung letztlich. Denn wir haben am ACCC kürzlich eine Pressemitteilung rausgegeben, die betraf die Zwei-Faktor-Authentifizierung mit SMS. Und da wollen wir ein bisschen drüber sprechen. Was ist eigentlich dieser Hack gewesen? Was wurde da technisch gemacht? Aber wir wollen vor allen Dingen auch darüber sprechen, warum wir Zwei-Faktor-Authentifizierung haben. Wo wir da Kritik haben. Wo sich was ändern müsste. Vielleicht sogar ein bisschen, was wir raten würden dem geneigten Computer-Benutzer. Und deswegen wollen wir, glaube ich, ein bisschen einsteigen mit der Geschichte. Also warum brauchen wir die sogenannten Trust Anchors? Warum müssen wir irgendwie ein bisschen mehr Mühe haben als früher? Wir können nicht immer nur einfach nur eine E-Mail-Adresse und ein Passwort eingeben. Und da wollen wir so ein bisschen mit anfangen und dann zu dem eigentlichen Hack kommen und ein bisschen darüber sprechen, was wir da technisch eigentlich vorliegen haben. Okay, Erdgeist wird zum Anfang. Wozu haben wir diese Trust Anchors? Warum ist die situation heute anders als vor 15 Jahren?
Was schon viele, glaube ich, auch technisch überfördert. Also generell glaube ich, das Backup vor dem Mobiltelefon ist weniger verbreitet als bei Computern, die so auf dem Schreibtisch stehen, ist mein Eindruck.
Einige Dienste verbieten dir auch schlicht, das von deinem Telefon woanders nochmal hinzuspeichern.
Das, oh ja, tatsächlich. Aber Apple, ich hab den Apple.
Nein, nicht nur Apple. Auch er?
Echt? Also du wirst den gar nicht.
Also einige Dinge, die in der Secure Enclave oder dann im TNT EE vom Android drin sind, kannst du nicht rausholen.
Das heißt, Backup ist auch nicht trivial.
Also ich nutze so eine Zwei-Faktor-App unter Android. Da kann ich was exportieren, das kann ich irgendwann wegspeichern. Und wenn mein Handy flöten geht, kann ich das woanders hin.
Aber ist das eine allgemeinkompatible Lösung? Schwerlich, oder? Ja, okay. Zumal man ja auch davon ausgehen muss, dass die Lösungen, die man in der Praxis jeden Tag benutzt für die verschiedenen Dienstleistungen eben nicht alle gleich sind und man unterschiedliche technische Wege gehen muss, nicht wahr?
Das auf jeden Fall. Also es ist manchmal auch nervig, schon wieder so einen zweiten Token eingehen zu müssen.
Dann auch noch die ganzen Kon... Wir haben ja von dieses Ausnachrichten kopieren, von wo dann gleich du in der eigenen App bist und dich dann der Betriebsdienst fragt, ob du nicht gleich aus der jüngst angegangenen SMS den 6-Ziffern-Code da rein kopieren möchtest. Ist total convenient, aber kann auch nach hinten losgehen. Auf der anderen Seite, wenn auf deinem Sperrbildschirm, ohne, dass du dich gegenüber deinem Telefon überhaupt authentifizieren musst, wenn dort gleich der Inhalt der SMS angezeigt wird, oder wenn andere Nachrichten angezeigt werden, hast du auch quasi kein Schutzniveau. Dann jeder, der dein Telefon mitnimmt, kann sich dann diese SMS zustellen und gleich anzeigen lassen. Das heißt, dort könnte man vielleicht nochmal in seinen Einstellungen nachschauen, ob man die Vorschau von den eingehenden Nachrichten nicht vielleicht für SMS zumindest. Die meisten Menschen benutzen ja ernsthaft SMS nicht mehr als Messenger. Das ist ja so die ganzen jungen Leute nehmen ja Signal, Fremar, Wemwatt.
Und damit verschieben wir das Problem wieder zur Nutzerin. Und schöner wäre es, wenn Betriebssystemhersteller das dann so bauen würden.
Genau, das Zwei-Faktor-Auth. SMS vielleicht gar nicht erst angezeigt werden auf dem Sperrbildschirm.
Na ja, bloß, aber dann hast du wieder, also ich möchte diese komische Duopol auch nicht in der Zukunft weiter haben. Also dann damit stärkst du ja diese beiden Platze schon weiter. Das ist ja eigentlich auch nicht, was wir wünschen. Also ja, vielleicht nicht.
Aber wenn die erst mal Dinge noch für ihre Kundschaft, die sie gerade haben, nicht schlimmer macht, ist auch schon mal was gewonnen.
Ja, das stimmt. Aber also sich zu verlassen auf diese beiden großen Konzerne, dass sie die Betriebssysteme da hingegen anfassen, das finde ich als Empfehlung. Damit bin ich auch nicht happy. Einfach, also fühle ich mich auch nicht wohl mit.
Nein, nein, nein. Noch mal wieder, wer sind deine Vertrauensanker? Wenn dein Vertrauensanker der Studenten dein Telefon ist, mit dem du dich da draußen ausweist, faktisch, musst du sie auch pflegen.
Na ja, damals meinst du aber, damals meinst du den Betriebssystemhersteller, der bei dir identisch mit dem Hersteller ist.
Ich meine jetzt unsere Hörerinnen da draußen. Wenn eure Mobiltelefone, eure Vertrauensanker sind, mit denen ihr euch da draußen in der Welt, guckt ob vielleicht noch ein einziger zusätzlicher Vertrauensanker, mit dem ihr später wieder Bootstrappen könnt, noch irgendwo im Kästchen liegt.
Das ist vielleicht ein guter Tipp, das stimmt.
Dass ihr dann nicht total aufgeschmissen seid, weil jeder kennt das, Telefon ist irgendwo rausgefallen, verloren gegangen.
In See geblumst.
Man kommt nicht mehr dran. Das sind so diese Schwarzstart-Fähigkeiten, einmal in sich zu gehen, zu üben. Was würde wohl passieren? Klar, ich mache Backups, aber hab da mal Restore gemacht. Hab da mal geguckt, wie ihr euch dann wieder an den Harren aus den Sumpf ziehen könnt, wenn euer Endgerät hops gegangen ist.
Ja, wir können da keine gute Lösung präsentieren. Aber zumindest ein paar dieser Hinweise, ja, das stimmt. Das lässt mich natürlich auch ein bisschen unzupredend zurück. Wollen wir nicht doch nochmal mit einem positiven Ende haben über die gute Utopie, wie es denn sein sollte, reden?
Alle Menschen sind nett zueinander.
Wir brauchen keine Passwörter.
Also, okay, das ist auch nicht... Also das Problem wird uns ganz sicherlich viele Jahre begleiten. Da hab ich glaube keine Zweifel dran. Dann muss ich dieses chaosradio leider auf dieser Note beenden. Wir müssen Markus Richter hier in dieser Stelle grüßen, von dem wir gehofft hätten, dass er ein anderes Ende findet. Markus Richter ist sonst der Moderator des chaosradio, den wir hier aufgrund seiner Urlaubstätigkeit heute vermissen. Aber ich glaube, so richtig werden wir keinen technischen Weg gefunden, einen positiven Ende zu finden. Ja, dann können wir nur sagen...
Dann danken wir an der Stelle mal Konstanze Kurz für die moderation. Dem Cantorkel, dass er es aus dem weiten Berlin hierher geschafft hat. Und dem Danimo, der heute für uns die Regler geschubst hat.
Und der ganzen chaosradio Crew, die sich hoffentlich in den nächsten Wochen sogar noch erweitert. Denn wir werden vielleicht ein paar mehr mal gucken. Und das nächste Mal wartet euch, wenn wir im Wechsel vom chaosradio immer die dicken Bretter haben. Eine Folge von Dicke Bretter. Und damit beenden wir mit lieben Grüßen das chaosradio 293.